you
ladies and gentlemen let's welcome
president Tony Tan King young
design of the year be together family
and progress programming with join Frank
this is what happens in a wonderful
country like this when you're working
with one class renowned artist and
insightful curator ever-supportive
national museum of singapore and lastly
master
Thank You top designer via dell inspiron
23 all in one can see
as a singapore top growth study here
work here design I want to I'm always
inspired to come up with world-class
design that really improved humanity
design of the year gardens by the bank
for this project we created something
special for Singapore particularly for
Singapore and possible audience
therefore it is unique design of the
year initial signature
and most of all I'd like to thank my
dead ket it's definitely more than just
the forums it's there are a lot of
people involved in project and already
tagged in us as well as the
collaborators the side of the year
rakesh up house
I would like to take my client is the
young un geniune or without the faith
sometimes blind faith and support this
shop hospital at the city's right now
design of the year part royal mp3
I have to tank the client your L who
have done for jobs with so far two of
which we have wonderful PDF or for being
so bowl encourages to except a radical
scheme that benefit not just themselves
but also city at large thank you you are
design of the year started by the bay
in making this building we wanted to
make something that was open public
space where people could come easily
because they like a nest egg when so the
building has more walls it is open
throughout the design of via Singapore
like
I will like to thank the organizers
specially designed Singapore who really
supported us right from the start also
the designers jen's amulets are melvin
the relay room Theon and shan way you do
not just design criticize but hot tub
designs design of the year snapware eco
the winner of this award meant a lot to
us the team as well as the whole company
it's on mastery when I received the good
news i have been running almost jumping
around my studio this is an announcer
simple good news yes we make it we
wander a walk designer the Patrick chair
in particular I would like to turn out
mr. nuinn son my first design mentor
that has for teaching me that to make
design you have to take a position and
to fight and some time to be
unreasonable designer of the year
rickard yeah
the practice of architecture is never a
one-man show and i'd like to share this
award with all my staff past and present
half a turn off to all of you most of
all I dedicate this award to the late
brother Joseph McNally to encourage me
to pursue architectural studies in
university when I was taking my a-levels
brother benelli thank you for
inspiration designer of the year of
and she stopped my friends were saying
that since where you question we should
probably make a crown or even like an
evening dress more better than you know
just steal the limelight miss Dickman
yeah but I told them that I'm not yet
the main statement I'm here to make a
difference design of the year
a lot of people always tell me that a
creative person can away with a business
this first one is problem being 50
points about money but then again I saw
it differently or rather we both saw it
differently i think one is like olive
oil ones that was me I think we make
good dressing designer every year
I think to be a floral designer we need
a god Connie karate hit in testing
everything you need it because you know
Singapore is very practical you want to
pay your flowers I think Harriet ok the
righteous diamond that's so true
I like possibly thank my wife my she
she's unwavering her support my work
when everybody says is ugly she's the
only ones says it's nice so thank you